the partial government shutdown is now
in day 28 with no talks plan to break
that stalemate House Democrats have
voted to reopen government agencies but
President Trump says he won't go along
without funding for a border wall a few
House Republicans have voted with the
Democrats including congressman will
heard he's from Texas he is the only GOP
member representing a district along the
southern border and it happens to
include more of the border than any
other district congressman Hurd joins us
at the table good morning to you there
is much to discuss with you today but
first let's start with the shutdown it
seems to be so tit-for-tat and so
personal in the meantime will you've got
close to 800,000 people who are still
not getting paid you have any
suggestions on how we end it and move
along okay I think the way we end this
is stop with the preconditions have
everybody come together let's stop
worrying about a democratic solution or
a Republican solution and come up with
an American solution sounds reasonable
but it is and when you look at look
there's 400,000 people came into the
country illegally last year we have 67
billion illegal drugs coming into our
country we should be able to secure our
border but the people that are involved
in securing our border right now are not
getting paid and so the people that are
keeping us safe not getting paid they
should be able to get paid for their
work this is having an impact on cyber
security as well because there's
officials within DHS who are protecting
our digital infrastructure not all of
them are on staff when we're fully
staffed we don't have enough people
coast guard who's responsible for
stopping a lot of drugs from coming in
our country they're having to go to to
food pantries in order to get fed this
makes no sense and we should be able to
work together you remember the
president's own party you're a
Republican why not meet with him
look I meet with everybody there's a lot
of conversations that are going on I'm
trying to talk about how we can solve
this the way we're gonna solve this is
with technology building a wall from sea
to shining sea is the most expensive and
least effective way to do border
security there are parts of the border
where Border Patrol's response time is
measured in hours two days a wall is not
a physical barrier when it takes you
hours to or days to respond to something
so we should be using technology DHS
Department of Homeland Security has new
programs that are trying to implement
but guess what we can
implement them because the government is
shut down and so this kind of Congress
we need to all work together to solve
this problem let's talk about the secure
Fence Act with everybody already passed
let's double down on technology along
the border let's make sure our ports of
entry are robust hey we're at three
point nine percent unemployment we need
workers
so let's streamline immigration at at
the same time and deal with the root
causes which is violence and lack of
economic opportunities in Central
America State Department is shut down as
well to USAID is shut down and they have
a role in doing that so let's talk about
the ramifications of this shutdown your
former intelligence official how
concerned are you about the TSA and what
we're seeing at legal ports of entry
right now the TSA is such an important
group in protecting our nation it is
still easier for a terrorist for al
Qaeda or Al Shabaab or Isis to get a
fake passport from Europe and get on a
plane and come through our ports of
entry that's why I TSA is so important
and the fact that there are some of the
lowest paid federal employees in the
entire government the fact that they're
having to work without getting paid the
fact that they're having to call in sick
because they can't pay for day care and
they have to take care of their kids you
know not having those people at our
Airport is is dangerous imagine
congressman if they all called in sick
and just shut down everybody
somebody would have to do something to
get the kind of you you know you talk
about what needs to be done and
everybody knows that but nobody's doing
it can you you're also on the Homeland
Security Committee I am the president
has said this is such an emergency it
requires this shutdown ordered for us
where the emergency is you see it at the
border comes in terms of all of the
emergencies that the United States faces
well if it was an emergency the people
that are dealing with the emergency
should get paid in order to handle the
emergency but 67 billion dollars in
drugs are coming in that's a problem in
some communities there are more
overdoses from drugs or deaths from some
overdoses than being killed on you know
in cars or in homicides so that is a
crisis that our country's having to deal
with but that's something that has
existed over multiple administrations
and it's something we should be able to
do
right you do have people that are you
know illegal kingpin human smugglers
congressman what I'm trying to figure
out is whether maybe the measures are
wrong to deal with this emergency but
you buy the idea that this is an
emergency requiring this kind of
emergency action are you no I don't
believe in the shutdown that's why I'm
one of the few Republicans that have
voted to make sure we keep the
government open border security is
important we can defend our border we
can chase Isis we can deal in
Afghanistan we can try to bring Kim
jong-un and North Korea to bear we can
handle all these problems and the best
way to do that is by making sure the
folks that are on the ground that are
dealing with these issues are getting
paid and our agencies are before you go
can I ask you about better O'Rourke
people it's you know a road trip you can
either get very close or you can get
very very snippy with each other he's he
seems to be thinking about running for
president do you think he should I know
it's his decision yeah but do you think
that he should look it's betos decision
and I think you know what is do you
think he inspired a lot of people he's
honest he's charming he's willing to
work with folks I got to have an
experience with him and we did the road
trip where we learned way more unites us
and divides us as a country and that's
something that I think he understands
woody began it in your opinion I think
he's going to have a difficult time and
this is something that he's going to
have to explore and talk with his family
but I think a lot of people are excited
about his his potential candidacy
congressman Hurd from the great state of
Texas yes Alamo City that's right city
Fionna is a Texas girl to go in there
today hopefully thank you so much
congressman thank you